It's time to update
your Weather App again.
Here's what I want you to do.
Add a gulp build project to your app.
If you're not familiar with gulp check
out the instructor notes below for
a starter file you can use and
to get a starting guide.
Then replace your existing service
worker with one created by sw precache.
Be sure to use the runtime caching
option to cache the app data.
When you've completed this step,
your app should work exactly
the same as it did before.
But now you've simplified
the build process and
reduced some of the headaches of
ruling your own service worker.
That means if you change
a single file on the App Shell,
only that file will need to be updated.
Be sure to compare your app to
the link in the instructor notes below
to make sure it works exactly the same.
And if you want to learn more about
gulp, check out the tooling and
automation course linked in
the instructor notes below.